finding yourself in a legal
misunderstanding with the police can put
you in a difficult position eric
palacios from eric palacios and
associates the sponsors of this segment
tell us what to do in case of being
accused of a crime
welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney
eric palacios today we're going to tell
you three things you need to do if
you're accused of a crime number one you
have the right to remain silent you can
choose to not answer questions and you
should not answer questions number two
don't ever consent to a search either of
your person your vehicle or your
property sometimes the police will ask
you the question in a tricky manner do
you mind if we search if you say yes or
no they can twist it to mean that you
did give consent so your response should
be clear i do not consent to a search
and number three
ask to speak to your attorney you need
to do this in a clear manner so the
police will stop questioning you this
has been the legal minute don't forget
to download my free app eric palacio's
legal app
and for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call at
you can also 702-444-7777 their website
at ericpalacioslaw.com